اهلا بك سهام اهلا بكافه مشاهدي مسائل
العربيه من جاده قباء او مسار قباء هذا
المسار الذي يربطه بين مسجد قباء والمسجد
النبوي تحول هذا المسار الى مكان للتنزه
ومقصد للزوار والمصلين وكذلك اهالي
المدينه المنوره يتحدث على مسافه هذا
المسار يصل الى ثلاثه كيلو مترات يربط بين
المسجد قباء والمسجد النبوي تمتهيئه هذا
المكان وانسنت هذا المكان ليكون متنزه
ومتنفس لزوار المسجد النبوي وكذلك المصلين
وايضا اهالي المدينه المنوره تحول هذا
المكان الى منطقه فعاليات ومنطقه يستهدفها
الزوار من خلال وخصوصا في اوقات الافطار
يحرص اهالي المدينه والزوار على الفطور
على الافطار في هذه المنطقه لما بها من
مطاعم ومقاهي تقدم الاكل والثقافه المدنيه
بشكل كبير جدا كما تشاهدون في يوم 21
اعداد كبيره من الز المصلين ان يحرصوا اهل
المدينه على التغيير احيانا من الافطار في
منازلهم الى الاماكن العامه والمتنزهات
مثل جاده قوات تم تحويل هذه المنطقه او تم
تسميتها برمضانيه قبى نشاهد الشريك
والكبده وبعض الماكولات المهمه مثل
السمبوسه والقطايف المدينيه وغيرها من
الماكولات المهمه التي يحرص عليها اهالي
المدينه اليوم اشتريك وجبه اساسيه والكبده
والفول هي من الوجبات الرئيسيه جدا في هذه
المنطقه اليوم هنا تمت هذا المكان بكافه
الفعاليات والخدمات اللوجستيه التي يحرص
عليها الاهالي مثل دورات المياه والمحال
التجاريه والمحال التذكاريه لبيع تذكرات
المدينه وكذلك منتزهات الاطفال بشكل كبير
كما نشاهد لنا امامكم الكاميرا العوائل
تحرس بشكل كبير على زياره هذه المنطقه
ايضا في الجانب الاخر هنالك مسار مخصص
بالاناره والتشجير وكذلك دورات المياه
وغيرها من
المكونات التي بشكل كبير اهالي المنطقه
والزوار هذه المنطقه الاساسيه من المنطقه
او كان يسمى هذا المكان بدرب السنه انه
كان الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم يذهب من
مسجد قبائل المسجد النبوي والعكس الان روح
ودكم الدوره السعاده او الكبده على ما
يقولوا يعني الكبده وجبه اساسيه اوليتكم
معانا اليوم ونذوقكم والكبده وغيرها من
الوجبات المهمه المدينيه التي يحرص عليها
يعني انا افهم اليوم احنا فطرنا صراحه مع
الاداره الكبده افهم من هيك يا سلطان انه
انت ما راح تفارق هذا المكان من هون
للايام العيد حتضلهم
حقيقه هذا المكان كافطار كتنزه كتمشيه
كتبضؤ الاسواق يعني زي ما تشوفين ما شاء
الله اعداد كبيره من الزوار موجودين في
هذه المنطقه المنطقه صراحه جاذبه وملفته
كثير الاهالي انه يحرسوا ويتذوقوا
الماكولات والمشروبات وغيرها من الاشياء
الجميله التي يعني تنال استحسان كثير من
الاهالي انا اليوم المدينه تعمل على
مشاريع انسنه كبيره جدا في الطرقات
والحدائق والمنتزهات وغيرها من المناطق
يعني احنا بصراحه انتوا كلمتونا في بدايه
البرنامج وحتى اماكن الكبده زي الناس
وشريك لكن بنعوض احنا بعد اللايف ان شاء
الله ونلتهم هذه الوجبات
العربيه بيستاهل يا سلطان
شكرا جزيلا لك سلطان السلمي طبعا بكل
تاكيد يعطيك العافيه شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات